how do you uh
train to become better at negotiating
um in business in uh in life yeah just
small Stakes practice for high stakes
results I mean decide what what kind of
negotiating resonates with you I mean
what's that means small Stakes practice
for high Stakes or small states so small
little
incremental like picking up girls at a
bar what are we talking about Well it
can't be uh for some people that's
that's high stakes practice
well you know labeling labeling mirrors
what are the basic tools of great
negotiation labeling mirroring
paraphrasing summarizing
so you start you start labeling a mirror
people that you just have in regular
interactions with just to gain a feel
for whether or not you can read
somebody's affect or how accurate your
read is to get better at it
and so you know label the
the Lyft driver
or the grocery store clerk
or a person behind the airline counter
at the at the airport so putting a label
on their affect or throwing something at
them
that because negotiations of parable
perishable skill emotional intelligence
is perishable
so seeing if you can indicate that you
understand our label
um one of my favorite labels to throw
out on somebody which you know maybe
re-level I might look at somebody who
looks distressed and I'll go tough day
so
several years ago
um at the counter at LAX oh well I'm
waiting the line to get to the counter
and a lady behind the counter is clearly
making a point to not meet my eyes so
that I don't approach and she looks and
so like you know you know when you're
next in line and they're making sure
that you don't need eyes
and I'm thinking to myself all right so
they're having a bad day so I woke up
and as soon as I approach the counter I
go tough day
and she kind of
snaps around
and she goes no no no how can I help you
it goes out of her way to help me
now I'm practicing but I also know it
made her feel better it relieves some of
the stress so now I'm going through TSA
I want to look for people having a tough
day it's a good place to find a good
place to find and practice
and I'm rolling through the line and I
realize I haven't tossed a label out on
any one of these guys and and there's
this guy watching the bags come out of
the X-ray machine he's just kind of got
an indifferent look on his face and I go
tough day
and he kind of goes I can see from his
body language like no
and I go just another day huh and he
goes yeah just another day you know he
felt seen but I missed and I'm
practicing and I'm trying to stay sharp
so these are the few words with just a
few words you're trying to like quickly
localize the effect and not live on it
very very very analytically said thank
you
thank you
I'm not letting it go
I love it
um it does this thing apply to just
conversation in general
is how to get better conversation I
think a lot of people struggle they have
insecurities they have anxiety about
conversation I as funny as it's to say I
have a lot of anxiety about conversation
is that it is basically do the same kind
of practice practice some of the
techniques yeah genuinely just trying to
make sure you heard somebody out